professor when it comes to
limiting climate change how important is
this rainforest
it's very important
it has two different roles one is
you have emissions every year from
deforestation
and also from degradation which
has actually been shown
various studies via more than
deforestation from logging and fires and
so forth
and
forests that's still standing
so that's one thing which is a
significant part of global warming but
what is really
[Music]
most frightening is the stock of carbon
that is still
in forested standing so that if
the amazon forest were to be
transformed into a savannah or if it
were
were to be
cut down burned and so forth uh
within a few years that would
be very significant pushing the climate
system past the tipping point where
global warming is out of control
because
really
the most that we can do is not emit
anything else if we don't burn a single
barrel of oil we don't cut down another
tree it's only 13 billion tons of carbon
but
by the fifth assessment report from the
ipcc so if there's more than 13 billion
tons coming out of forest fires and the
tundra melding and all these things all
over the world
it means
global warming gets out of control so
the amazon is central to that
that question and how close could we be
to that tipping point do you think well
quite close because
first of all there's several tipping
points and you have tipping points in
terms of temperature
the 1.5 degree
limit that the cop26 is trying to
enforce
uh is more or less where these tipping
points are for the climate and also
uh you have a tipping point for
deforestation so that you can only
clear a certain percentage
of the forest and not have it just
disintegrate on its own and we're close
to that too
so do you have
any faith that this meeting in glasgow
could come up with something some sort
of deal
that would involve the brazilian
government obviously that would stop
what is going on here or reverse what is
going on here
uh
certainly the current brazilian
government is not
likely to to change its behavior
dramatically on its own but
certainly if if this deal
uh involves the countries that are
importing soy and beef and so forth
especially china
then they could have a big effect so
this global pledge to
uh have zero deforestation by 2030
for example if china were to say we
won't import any of your products unless
you have zero deforestation then it
would have it would really happen
um brazil says it will sign this pledge
for deforestation
um
do you
value their word
well
uh what brazil has been promising
so far including president bolsonaro's
speech remote speech to the cop
was to only halt
illegal deforestation
not all deforestation but
as i understand the global pledges for
all deforestation and if that actually
happens it would be very important
problem is that
there are two ways to stop illegal
deforestation one is to actually stop
deforestation and the others just
legalize everything that's going on and
it's that second path that is actually
happening
yeah so i mean are you optimistic
pessimistic or
where are you on the future of the
rainforest that you love so much
well i think it's important not to be
either one that is if you're pessimistic
and you think everything's
lost cause anyway then no one does
anything and if you're optimistic and
think everything's taking care of itself
you also don't do anything so you really
have to be focused on the problem and it
is possible to have major changes
and you can't wait too long in the case
of the amazon
you